Nazi paken Nazi uh welcome back to the
show you're on your usual spot right now
in our former uh Studio but now as a
player difficult game difficult opening
but you bounced back after that and that
uh finale of this game was just
absolutely crazy tell us your story
about this
game thank you Christian it's good to be
back again as a player I've missed
playing uh yeah today's game was
absolutely crazy uh in time trouble
position got so complicated and when I
played G4 and E4 I wasn't sure if I was
winning or losing to be honest and even
towards the end when I had two queens I
still had to calculate and make sure she
didn't have any Perpetual checks so I
can't wait actually to go back to my
room and check it with the engine well
you have the engine right here so let's
check it together this was a critical
moment uh after the 40th move when you
played that move King to H4 did you you
find it in the first few minutes did you
spend a cuz you spent a lot of time you
spend like 13 15 minutes between that so
when did you spot this move King to
H4 uh I spotted it after she played
Queen D3 right away and the reason I
spent 15 minutes was after King H4 I was
looking at Queen C2 Queen takes D6 and
queen G2 exactly yes and what was your
move after Queen toad of f4 Queen H6
best move only move in fact yes if you
take with the king queen to H5 you take
with the pawn right F7 F5 Falls and just
pick up a piece mhm that was nice
calculation Nazi um you must be feeling
pretty good about your form right now uh
seeing all these details in the position
is such a tense
position yes especially in time trouble
so I'm pretty happy with my calculation
today I hope to continue like that every
game very good well congratulations guys
any questions for our sole victory in
the Ladi section yeah well uh Nasi uh as
we know it's much harder to be a
commentator than a player um how do you
feel as a as a player not a commentator
do you feel what's the different
pressures that you're
under I'm actually really jealous of
both of you right
now as you should it is so much more
stressful to play um but at the same
time as much as I love commentating the
feeling that I have right now after a
win you can only get this from playe
exactly exactly well it was a fantastic
win and good luck tomorrow and the rest
of the tournament we hope to see you
often thank you so much absolutely and
two games remaining